French president Emmanuelle McCourt
likes to be seen as a passionate
European forgotten koala hop week what
you believe in Europe you have to
believe in it fully and that means you
have to stick to certain rules upon
Boris Fez is also steadfastly
pro-european but he's disappointed in
macomb the German businessman sells
enclosures for swimming pools his
company is located near the border with
France where he exports a quarter of his
production however he's very
disappointed about a law that McCole
spearheaded during his tenure as Frances
economy minister because of it Fez now
has to wait weeks for construction
permits
disputes on its once okay it feels like
a straitjacket next year we'll have to
pass on the costs of these French
regulations to our customers because we
cannot afford to shoulder this burden
alone these costly registration
procedures are strictly regulated with a
2,000 euro fine for non-compliance and
4,000 for repeat offenses so we'll have
to tack on a makalah surcharge for our
French customers log the regulations
mean feds can no longer offer a speedy
and efficient service which is a big
selling point and he has to employ
people especially to deal with the
French bureaucracy the rules apply to
foreign companies wanting to do business
in France French parliamentarian puno
Bunnell says they're designed to protect
the French labor market that's why we
plan to expand these regulations next
year all sectors not just construction
companies will need to fill out the
additional paperwork and apply for an
extra permit rules may be complex but
they provide access to a part of our
market in exchange
yeah yeah the amok she says the new
rules are unjust and he thinks that
other european companies will also be
disadvantaged by Michaels policy he
decided to lodge a complaint with the
German government but it merely advised
him to file a lawsuit at the European
Court of Justice responses we got her
really frustrating
non-committal answers with no new
information just yes we know but we
don't have the answer and if you're
unhappy you can file a complaint many
other German companies share his
frustration Pascal Molly P fair from the
local branch of the Chamber of Commerce
represents German businesses here she
says thousands of them fear they'll have
to stop exporting to France and that
would also have a knock-on effect on the
French economy
dr. vivillon hi Axl I thought we'd all
live and work together more freely
according to the European ideal I think
that's been dented a bit because if
German companies can't cross over into
France can't operate easily then they
won't attend trade fairs and when the
trade fair business slumps the French
hotel sector and restaurants will all
face problems it's the whole problem has
been meeting with the heads of other
German companies he hopes they'll join
him in taking the case to the European
Court of Justice his company with its 30
employees depends on its exports to
France even more so now that it's just
invested half a million euros in a new
factory it's all just delaying tactics
for me as a businessman it means
continuing to struggle with this mess
without any hope of change and having to
entertain the possibility of getting out
of the French market altogether if
things don't improve for his fellows
always had faith in the European single
market he can't understand why barriers
are suddenly going up across Europe